imagine your high school history teacher
leaving school at three o'clock and
going straight to work his second job as
a UFC fighter meet Cody Gibson he
teaches history at Lucia Mar Unified
School District in California and he
also just fought at UFC 292 and although
he lost his fight he still ended up
winning big when it was all said and
done UFC president Dana White promised
Gibson a new contract after fans
bombarded him about Gibson's impressive
performance before this Gibson had been
fighting for several promotions since he
was released from the UFC in 2015 but
now he's back in the UFC and will
continue to still teach history in the
classroom